this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys this is Vadim with Mac's tech
and this right here is the 2019 Mac Pro
and we're gonna be playing some games on
it but we're going to be doing it a
little bit differently first of all this
is not a base model with a 5 ATX
graphics it's actually upgraded and it's
got the Vega 2 graphics option that
costs twenty four hundred dollars so
that's going to be interesting to see
and this right here is actually Apple's
6k Pro display XDR and what we're gonna
do in this video is play at 6k
resolution
we're in Windows boot camp right now and
look at that
six thousand sixteen by 33 84 so let's
go ahead and jump into modern warfare
now I want to tell you guys the
difference between resolutions and y6k
is so important with a 1080p monitor
you're running about two million pixels
and then going up to 4k that's around
8.3 million going up to 5k is around
fifteen million in 6k is over twenty
million pixels so that's a massive
difference between 4k and 6k 8.3 to over
20 million pixels so that's why this is
going to be around two-and-a-half times
harder to run then trying to run 4k and
a lot of people actually don't run 4k
because they get a lot lower frame rate
so this is going to be very interesting
to see how this performs so I'm here in
the settings and you guys can see that
we have 32 gigabytes of vram and it's
only using four of them look at that
look at this bar right here that's crazy
right here you can see we're playing a
6k resolution we've set the texture
resolution to normal normal particle
quality high we have the shadows to
normal and we've turned off the
anti-aliasing completely because at 6k
resolution
you don't need anti-aliasing so back
when the 5k iMac was last updated we
actually played fortnight at 5k and we
played 5k at medium settings and we
noticed that it looked sharper and
better than 4k at Ultra so that's why we
have 6k going right here with everything
set to normal it's gonna look really
good so one thing that's special about
the Pro display XDR is that you're
getting a 1 million to 1 contrast ratio
but it's an
see display so it actually looks like
it's OLED you get very very deep blacks
but it's an LCD and Apple is doing this
by having over 500 local dimming zones
that are dimming the rest of the image
that's not bright making that good of a
contrast ratio so all these settings are
ready and we're about to get into the
game I think we're gonna play some gun
game but before we do that let me tell
you about our sponsor Squarespace
if you've been thinking about making
your own website Squarespace is
seriously the best way to go
I built an engaging website for my
wife's cleaning business with literally
no web making experience you just choose
a template customize blocks of text and
images and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable and it's
been running flawlessly for almost two
years bringing in new clients thanks to
his built-in SEO tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
literally anything else go to
Squarespace calm for a free trial and
use our custom link below when you're
ready to launch - save 10% on your first
purchase of a website or domain all
right let's go how do we add oh look at
that 55 FPS guys we're running 6k
resolution at 55 FPS 60 FPS are you
kidding me whoa I barely got that guy oh
see that all right so you guys might be
noticing these textures that are kind of
glitched out now we experienced this
before when we did our last video with
the Mac Pro and we're still having this
issue now a lot of people recommended
going to bootcamp drivers comm and
installing the new bootcamp drivers and
we did that but here's the issue we
weren't able to get 6k resolution with
those other drivers only these drivers
that are a little bit messed up are
working with 6k so now we're back with
these drivers and although we're having
some of these little glitches and messed
up textures the FPS is actually decent
especially for running 6k resolution
which is insane everything looks
literally amazing right now
everything's so sharp
Oh got him oh so close
got him now you might be thinking 50 FPS
sucks but considering we're playing a 6k
resolution that's actually really good
so just to test out how much FPS we can
get I'm actually gonna go and turn it
down to regular 4k alright check that
out a hundred and ten FPS at 4k and
we're still experiencing these little
glitches and look at that we're still
experiencing these messed up textures so
in reality if we had better drivers that
could run Oh at 6k almost Adam we had
better drivers that could run at 6k that
fix these issues we could actually get
even more FPS than we're getting right
now yeah oh I didn't get him
Oh finally
got him oh I almost had like another
dude probably so now I'm actually gonna
go back to 6k but I'm gonna try to see
if I can lower some settings to see if
we can achieve around 60fps right here
we are we just set a few things down to
low and it looks like our fps is still
around 50 now this is a different map so
maybe that has something to do with it
whoa Oh through the wall yes oh it's a
bro you missed huh right boys
boom yes
Goldeneye oh snap oh I reloaded now
although we weren't getting a consistent
60 FPS I actually played very smooth
because we didn't have very large drops
in FPS it would stayed fairly consistent
in the same range got away almost had
the guy oh I just shot him in the face
on accident that's hilarious
so it looks like I'm getting a little
bit worse FPS on this map nice oh you
guys man this display is immersive it's
just so massive so there you guys have
it 6k gameplay on the pro display XDR
with the Mac Pro not the base model the
model with the Vega 2 graphics no that's
actually not the best graphics you can
get you can get to Vega 2 duo's in this
thing so with just the Vega 2 we're able
to get around 50 to 60 FPS at 6k
resolution or over a hundred FPS at 4k
resolution with this awesome display
that has awesome contrast ratios very
very sharp image quality so there you
guys have it hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video if you did comment and like
down below and if you have not
subscribed yet click that circle above
to do so now and check out one of those
two videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]